hey what is up guys on to Bhd here and
better late than never
HTC ten final verdict as a smartphone
this is a really really good phone so
you probably already knew that but after
using this phone for the past couple
weeks I kind of realized it surprised me
how underrated it is it's just really
good at a lot of things and I think most
anyone would agree it's the complete
package so it pretty much nails
everything you look for in a flagship
smartphone so the build it nails that
this phone is all metal all the way
around so anytime you're holding it
you're touching metal which is awesome
and the sides are also pretty flat which
is important so even though it's kind of
a chunky phone it's easy to hold and
then for looks it has this big chamfer
all the way around the edges of the
rounded back and that really
characterizes this device so there's
plenty of other metal devices but the
chamfer color it sort of changes as it
catches the light from different angles
so it's really nice it's like classic
HTC hey you know what the most
underrated piece of hardware that
actually really makes a smart phone is
good buttons seriously and HTC ten has
great buttons a textured clicky power
button and a separate very tactile
clicky volume rocker so a good grade for
both of those the only knock I have on
the build is that it's not ip68
water-resistant but it is still IP 53
technically so it can handle a misting
just fine now the display it also pretty
much nails that so you're working with a
5.2 inch quad HD super LCD display it
looks good as you'd expect pretty
vibrant and color accurate not the
brightest thing in the world but you
know just barely visible in outdoor
sunlight and it looks great and sharp
everywhere else the speaker's this was
an interesting point compared to
previous HTC phones because those were
legendary for boomsound front-facing
speakers here on the HTC 10 we have two
speakers one larger driver on the bottom
for low and mid frequencies and then
another one up in the earpiece at the
top and the cutout for high frequencies
and they work together sort of like a
woofer and tweeter pair at it sounds
pretty good it's definitely way better
than the worst speakers out there so
that's good but
it's still no front-facing stereo pair
which is what I got used to from HTC in
the past even other devices now like my
Nexus 6p now obviously this isn't a big
deal to some people plenty of people
will use headphones anyway which are
great with this phone but it's something
to note this is a pretty
middle-of-the-road speaker setup
the specs yeah of course it nailed those
Snapdragon 820 chip Adreno 550 GPU 4
gigabytes of RAM and as a bonus
expandable storage so there's a SIM card
tray on one side and the other side a
micro SD card slot for those that
cherish that kind of glad these made it
come back in 2016 and in the performance
Department this phone has stayed fast I
kind of mentioned in the first
impressions video that it felt quick
obviously that's right out the box but
responsiveness is on point and this is
something HTC worked on a lot with their
new software and I've had no slowdowns
with day-to-day use with this guy so
opening and closing apps is quick
multitasking is quick and a lot of the
normal in-between stuff feels so quick
and snappy because the animations are
shortened a lot in fact just the
software in general on this phone since
8:00 is now one of my favorite skins
I've seen on Android to date in a long
time it's pretty close to stock Android
in look and feel and I like that not
just because it's stock ish but because
it's good and just that one extra level
of customization beyond a signage and
mod rom or something so you have HTC's
themes store and a couple extra features
here and there and hardware
optimizations but still a mostly stock
feel so I dig it removing duplicate apps
to clean the app drawer and make things
less confusing was a good move and not
overloading the phone with a whole bunch
of weird features and gestures and stuff
was also a good move keep saying simple
top all that off with a 3000 milliamp
hour battery and you're looking at
pretty consistently smooth performance
that actually lasts a whole day I'm a
lot happier with again the battery life
of flagship phones this year to this HTC
ten is getting me my four and a half
hours of screen on time and has great
standby so pretty much matches the
galaxy s7 if a little bit short and I
almost never use any of the power saving
features so I'm happy about that one
place that I'd say that this phone is
kind of lacking is the camera I'm not
recommending this phone to anyone
for the camera so if you're a person who
takes a lot of photos or a lot of videos
and is really into the camera this isn't
your number-one choice it's probably top
ten but it's not the best so if that's
what you're looking for then this is not
your phone HTC 10 is rocking a 12
megapixel camera with an F 1.8 aperture
optical image stabilization LED flash
and laser autofocus all good specs on
paper image quality wise it's just above
average so you can see from the shots
I've taken you can definitely get really
good photos and 4k videos out of this
phone no question especially in good
light so color accuracy is solid
nothing's too over sharpened or
oversaturated - which is cool and then
with the F 1.8 aperture you can also get
that nice shallow depth of field and
blurred background if you want and then
that also helps of course a lot
combining with OIS to do a little bit
better than average in low-light uh it
still breaks down but you know you get
the idea I think it tends to err err on
the side of overexposure definitely has
a bit more blown out highlights than
crushed shadows usually but since it's
doing auto HDR so quickly dynamic range
is also pretty good I put it in the top
few cameras on smartphones for sure but
again the galaxy s7 s and iPhones of the
world are going to take better photos
for sure overall if CC 10 gets a lot of
the little things right
stuff like the expandable storage like I
mentioned it's a nice bonus for people
who take a lot of videos and photos or
have a lot of music the fingerprint
sensor is also a nice touch it's pretty
quick not the quickest it's behind touch
ID and I'd say Samsung and Huawei but
top five for sure and things like the
super high quality DAC this smartphone
will actually drive your higher powered
headphones and those who pay attention
will notice the great audio from the
headphone jack of this guy there's also
airplay support right out the box on HTC
10 that's a first Ranny Android phone so
it has a lot going for it so at the end
of the day like we said this HTC 10 is a
really good phone it's not perfect by
any means definitely still has its
quirks what you might consider flaws but
it checks pretty much all the boxes and
it does most of what you would expect
out of a flagship smartphone so the
beauty the power and the nice clean OS I
think it'll be even more interesting
later this year now that works
to see at least the rumors point to an
HTC made Nexus phone coming out later
this year and then that should take a
lot of the design keys from this phone
but we'll reserve judgment until we see
that that's basically it for this review
thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys the next one bass